am 25 juni 1991 erklären sich das
heutige slowenien und kroatien für
unabhängig vom damaligen vielvölkerstaat
jugoslawien in den darauffolgenden tagen
versucht die jugoslawische volksarmee
diese abspaltung mit waffengewalt zu
verhindern
für österreich spitzt sich die lage
dramatisch zu als am grenzübergang
spielfeld die kämpfe auf
österreichisches territorium
überzuschwappen drohen das bundesheer
erhält erstmals in der zweiten republik
den befehl zur militärischen sicherung
und 7.700 österreichische soldaten gehen
in stellung
an diesen einsatz gedenkt man am
dienstag in kärnten und in der
steiermark bei gedenkveranstaltungen in
grab nach in kärnten bedankt sich
landeshauptmann peter kaiser für den
damaligen einsatz des bundesheeres
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
bedankt sich bei den zeit zeugen die
heute noch genau über vorgänge von
damals berichten können
[Musik]
in spielfeld in der steiermark
appelliert der steirische
landeshauptmann hermann schützenhöfer an
die jugend zu machen
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
dank den 19 91 eingesetzten soldaten und
betont die stetige einsatzbereitschaft
des bundesheeres und auch wenn man
keinen direkten vergleich mit vor 30
jahren ziehen darf und soll dann sei an
dieser stelle auch denjenigen danke
gesagt am höchsten punkt der pandemie
8000 soldatinnen die gibt es
mittlerweile im unterschied zu vor 30
jahren und soldaten die im inland und im
ausland ihren einsatz für sich
[Musik]